hi my name is Isabelle Sherrill and
today I'm going to be talking to you
about how robust principal component
analysis can be used for modal
decompositions of fluid flows so this
work was recently accepted and will be
published in Physical Review fluids and
all of the code associated with what's
presented here is available on my github
so breaking down this title because it's
quite a mouthful I'm going to start with
the principal component analysis or PCA
aspect of this work so principal
component analysis also known as proper
orthogonal decomposition or P OD well
look we'll take a flow field or a
dataset and decompose it into a set of
modes and these modes are ordered
hierarchically in terms of how much
energy they possess and for this
canonical cylinder flow field which is
often used for as an example it is an
efficient representation of the foe
field because 99% of the energy
associated with this flow can be
represented in the first ten modes so
this is a great method that's used in a
variety of fields in a variety of
applications but it tends to start to
break down when sparse noise is
introduced and that's an commonly a
common issue in fluids so oftentimes our
flow fields don't look like that perfect
cylinder flow field they look a little
bit like more like this one where
they're messy and they have sparse noise
but what we want to do is we want to
decompose this into a low-rank space and
identify that sparse noise so that we
can get these more accurate accurate
representative representations of our
flow fields so the way we want to do
this is to use a method that was
previously developed in robust
statistics called robust principal
component analysis and robust principal
component analysis can take a dataset
that has low rank structure and identify
the sparse noise so here the example
shown is the eigenfaces dataset where
the faces all have low rank structure
they all have eyes nose and a mouth and
robust principal component analysis is
able
take that and identify that this
mustache is sparse and that it is noise
and that it is not it's a disguise it's
not really part of the faces and so the
sparse noise is able to be identified
and the method is able to see this face
and identify the face instead so that
low ranked face is evident and that
sparse is sort of separated out so what
we are actually doing and more
explicitly are mathematically is we want
to identify an L and an S matrix that
where the L matrix has minimal rank and
the S matrix is as farce as possible and
by sparse we want we mean that we wanted
to have as few nonzero components as
possible that means that most of the
components of s are 0 but where we are
identifying sparse noise those
components are nonzero since the rank of
L and the 0 norm of s are both non
convex we relaxed this to solve the
following where we are minimizing the
Frobenius norm of L
and the one norm of s and we introduced
this parameter lambda or lambda naught
as shown here where we have lambda
naught equals 1 over the max of the
dimensions of X and to be explicit the
dimensions of X are the columns are the
spatial dimensions so each row in the
matrix X is a spatial dimension and each
column represents one component in time
or one iteration in time
ideally lambda would be equal to 1
according to the original method but
since many of our datasets do not
exactly follow that they have low rank
structure with uncorrelated sparse noise
we use this as a tuning parameter to get
accurate results so keeping that in mind
if we have this lambda data set if we
have this flow past a cylinder data set
and we want to change lambda if we make
lambda too small then everything is
allocated to the sparse space and the
rank is too low if we make lambda too
large there's no noise reduction and
everything is considered low rank and
then rank is too high if we get lambda
just right we have this perfect
bisection between low rank structure and
sparse noise and that's what we're
aiming for this is a really nice example
but this noise is it's sort of ideal
it's completely sparse and uncorrelated
and somewhat unrealistic
instead what we're going to look at is
how this changes if we have noise that's
biased towards regions of high vorticity
this is a little bit more realistic for
many of our actual flow fields that
we're measuring because regions of high
vorticity are often of interest and
often very difficult to measure because
of their three-dimensional nature so
even though it looks like in the sparse
space all the way down there it looks
like there's structure in there it's
because the noise is correlated with
those regions and those regions are more
likely to have salt pepper noise
so now we're going to move on to the
modal decomposition aspect of this so if
we have if we want to look at the bottle
decompositions of this X matrix and this
L matrix then what we want to do is we
want to compare them to the true modes
so if we have the true modes and then we
compare the PCA modes we can see that
they're pretty much incoherent and very
difficult to interpret there isn't much
structure there there's somewhat of a
structure in the mean field in the first
mode but beyond that there's not much
there if we compare this to the our PCA
modes then we can see that there's some
structure there there's some coherent
structure and it starts to match the
true modes however if they're still a
little bit fuzzy and this is only for
two periods of vortex shedding being
analyzed if we increase that from two
periods to five periods we see it
improved results but not for the PCA
modes the PCA modes are still pretty
much incoherent so but for the our PCA
modes we can see that the they're much
clearer and have that same structure
that's evident in the true modes this is
a nice quantitative qualitative example
but if we want to look at this a little
bit more quantitatively we can see that
the PCA modes if we look at the DMV
eigenvalues that that the PCA DMV eigen
values are all clustered toward the
origin that means that they're
artificially damped whereas the true
modes are on the unit circle because
these are these asila torie modes that
are that shouldn't be damped and that's
shown in the our PCA modes where once we
get past a single period of vortex
shedding being analyzed the DMD eigen
values are on the unit circle so now if
we look at a cylinder PIV example so
this is an actual flow past a cylinder
measured at Reynolds number 413 we sort
of see similar trends where if we make
lambda too low low the rank is too low
if we make lambda too high
there's minimal noise reduction but we
have this happy medium that has this
nicer bisection however it's not exactly
clear what this value should be and
there's a trade-off between having
structure and your sparse matrix and
having noise reduction if we look at
those same modes we can see that the PCA
modes and the our PCA modes at a low
lambda value have degrade very quickly
so after the fifth mode for this case
that this low lambda value since lambda
is so low rank there isn't any structure
and that does not and that's not right
if we make lambda larger you can see
that the structure is more persistent
and that we have structure at higher
modes and you can see that if you look
at the singular values for each one of
these case cases where the light blue
shows the our PCA modes at lambda equals
zero point one where they have this
start drop buff and we speculate that
this method could be used that looking
at these singular values can be used to
determine what your optimal value of
lambda is but that would be future work
so finally we're going to look at this
sort of example that we use just to look
at this method and see how it performs
on data that we actually care about so
we have this cross flow turbine where we
have a frame and we're looking at the
wake and here we're looking at the you
velocity and or the free or the stream
wise velocity and you can see that there
are these regions of higher velocity
shown in yellow and cyan and the white
measurements are missing measurements so
here we're treating those corrupt
measurements those missing measurements
as corrupt measurements and if we look
at the traditional PIV processing
pipeline which is shown here where the
first frame is the cross correlated
frame then that vector validation is
performed and then finally interpolation
you can see the traditional processing
but it's very hard to interpolate when
you're missing many measurements that
are local locally because if you
have any local information then you're
interpolating from points that are very
far away so instead what we propose is
to use that global information and use
our PCA instead of interpolation and if
you look at the phase median for each
one of these cases they look very
similar where they differ is if you look
at the and just to be clear since this
is a periodic wake that this is a
structure that is passing through and
this is the same phase so this is the
median at every point of this phase and
if you look at the standard deviation at
each point at this face you can see that
for the traditional PIV processing the
interpolated case there are all these
really dark spots which means that the
this region is very inconsistent from
pretty jitter a ssin
for each at each period whereas the our
PCA is much smoother and that's very
promising so that's all I have to share
for you and the this again this work is
available on archive and it is the code
associated with this is on my github but
just to summarize I want to say that
this is a pretty efficient method to use
that you can use on your data set it's
based on the SVD also and it's all of if
you want to try this out please check
out my github thank you